donc ça c'est les petits casse noisette
qui va défendre clara philippe prépare
son prochain spectacle du scénario à la
mise en scène
le marionnettiste créer un univers bien
à lui et sa créativité se nourrit de
notre quotidien
la pandémie de coronavirus l'a
d'ailleurs inspiré je me suis amusé à
faire ce chinois qui vendent des chauves
souris parce qu'il faut bien coller un
petit peu l'actualité avec avec le côté
classique
donc il ya toujours une double lecture
dans ses spectacles toujours toujours
philippe tirera les ficelles de casse
noisette et de ses amis pour la première
fois le 6 septembre
mais en attendant le marionnettiste doit
assurer un autre spectacle au parc de la
tour de saint cyr sur loire avec une
jauge diviser par deux le marionnettiste
a joué deux fois plus pendant tout l'été
une manière de sauver sa saison estivale
oui mais les loups ne savent pas voler
qui est aujourd'hui c'est pierre et le
loup pendant près d'une heure
philippe donne vie à six personnages
différents non non non et non
comment ça non non non et non j'aime
raconter des histoires aux enfants
certainement parce qu'on n'a pas raconté
beaucoup quand j'étais gamin bon je
pense que plusieurs racontent existe ça
me plaît beaucoup
puis la technique de la marionnette à
fils je la trouve je trouve riches
on peut faire ce qu'on veut avec une
marionnette à fils on peut la faire
marcher courir sauter c'est vraiment un
être vivant part entière pour moi un
métier de l'ombre que philippe
n'échangerait pour rien déjà 34 ans que
le tourangeau fait sourire les petits et
les grands
rien bientôt merci d'être passé au
castelet de la toile j'aimerais lourd à
mettre en cage
[Musique]